a trump supporting failed Republican
candidate has been arrested for his
involvement in the shootings that took
place at the homes of multiple elected
Democrats
this is the United States of America in
2023 the world looks on in horror
the Albuquerque Journal reports failed
Republican candidate arrested in
shootings targeting Democratic
politicians homes Albuquerque Police
yesterday
arrested the man they say is The
Mastermind behind a recent string of
shootings targeting Democratic lawmakers
homes the suspect Solomon Penna is a
republican who unsuccessfully ran in
November made repeated claims the
election was rigged and appears to have
attended the January 6th riots in DC
around 3 P.M APD SWAT team swarmed a
condo complex executed a search warrant
made announcements for Penna who they
said may be armed with a firearm to
surrender as drones flew overhead within
an hour officers arrested Penna who's
accused of paying four men to shoot at
the homes of two County Commissioners
and two state legislators investigators
also believe penno is present for at
least one of those shootings Penna ran
unsuccessfully in house district 14
claimed on social media heat should have
won where have we heard that before he
also visited three of the targeted
officials homes unannounced in November
he showed up and said it was a fraud the
election should not be certified APD
essentially discovered what we had all
feared and what we had suspected these
shootings were indeed politically
motivated said Albuquerque mayor Tim
Keller they were dangerous acts not only
to these individuals but fundamentally
also to democracy what a
Trump supporting Republican thinks he
won an election he lost and is willing
to use violence against political
opponents not a shock sadly just another
day in the United States of America
under this authoritarian wannabe
dictatorial Republican party that prays
at the altar of Donald Trump
um in the back story of this is
interesting and disturbing in early
January APD disclosed it was
investigating several shootings
targeting Democratic elected officials
homes around the city
they said Bernalillo County Commissioner
Adrian barboas Southeast Albuquerque
home had been struck by eight bullets on
December 4th and a week later on
December 11 more than 12 bullets hit
County Commissioner Debbie O'Malley's
North Valley home they just show up and
shoot at the home so you understand
what's Happening Here Right
on January 3rd shots rang out at State
Rep Linda Lopez's home in Southwest
Albuquerque three bullets went through
her daughter's bedroom as the 10 year
old slept
after news of the investigation
circulated State Rep Javier Martinez
current nominee for house Speaker then
rep for district 11. inspected his home
and noticed it too had damage from
bullets he had heard gunfire outside on
December 8th and believes that's when
the shooting occurred
these people are disgusting and these
are the very people who are the opposite
of what they claim to be by the way this
is terrorism in my mind this is
absolutely terrorism because this is
meant to send a message not only to
these individuals whose homes were shot
but more broadly when you say oh
Democratic legislator homes are being
shot it is meant to scare people who are
Democrats vote for Democrats would
consider running as Democrats Etc this
is a form of terrorism we must all ask
the question
how could Hunter Biden's laptop have
prevented this oh no sorry no no that's
that's wrong I'm I uh I I'm now too
sucked into Hunter Biden's laptop
because of Republicans we must all ask
the question
if they claim to be for Law and Order
but they do this are they really for Law
and Order
if they claim to be for democracy but
they want candidates who lost to still
get sworn into office are they really
for democracy and for counting all of
the legal votes and all of those things
the answers of course to all of these
questions are no they are not
they claim to be for these things and
they actually are not it is Terrorism
they found the guy let's now hope they
really throw the book at him and
prosecute him to the absolute fullest
extent of the law the signal needs to be
sent this isn't acceptable the problem
is we have too many in this country who
believe it is acceptable when you do
polls and we looked at them maybe six
weeks ago and you ask Americans is it
acceptable to use violence to achieve
your political goals more people than
ever and many more Republicans than
Democrats now say it is indeed
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you were
supporting good jobs helix sleep is
giving my audience 350 off plus two free
pillows this is the place to get pillows
you know what I mean go to Helix
sleep.com slash Pacman and use code
Helix partner the link is down below